Quelques questions au Docteur de
Serres.
La quatrième dose, c'est pour
qui? On voit que l'on ouvre
toutes les tranches d'âge qui
devrait y aller.- Le comité sura
émis ses recommandations la
semaine dernière disant que les
gens à qui il recommandait la
vaccination avec sa deuxième
dose de rappel ou la quatrième
dose depuis le début aux gens de
80 ans et plus qui vivaient dans
la communauté. Et aux personnes
vivant en CHSLD et dans les arts
PA. Il y avait aussi les gens
immunodéprimés. Le comité sur
l'immunisation des acquêts si le
ministère veut élargir à des
groupes d'âges plus jeunes,
c'est possible. On n'est pas sûr
du bénéfice que l'on aura avec
la vaccination des
jeunes parce que déjà même chez
les gens de 80 ans et plus
envoyait une très bonne
persistance de la
donnée par la troisième dose
contre les hospitalisations.
- Quelqu'un de 65 ans, 67 ans
qui en relativement bonne
forment, vous lui dîtes d'y
aller ou d'attendre?
- Ce qui est dit actuellement
par le directeur national de
santé publique ce que la dose
est disponible pour ce qui ont
entre 60 et 79 ans qui veulent
venir la chercher. Ce n'est pas
une recommandation forte comme
on a fait pour les gens de 80
ans et plus. Donc, l'exemple que
vous me donnez de quelqu'un qui
serait en bonne santé et qui
aurait reçu ces trois doses,
c'est pas une grande nécessité
d'avoir cette dose additionnelle
maintenant. D'autant plus que la
vague actuelle va durer quelques
semaines, mais le rendez-vous
que les gens vont avoir va peut-
être arriver au moment où la
vague va être en décroissance et
à ce moment, le bénéfice devient
très faible de la quatrième
dose. On est mieux d'attendre à
l'automne probablement alors que
l'on s'attend à avoir une
remontée des cas et un
éloignement depuis la deuxième,
troisième dose qui va rendre une
dose de rappel plus intéressante
des précipitations sur les
informe même sur les vieux. Si
on a eu la covid et beaucoup de
gens l'ont, est-ce qu'on est
protégée, est-ce qu'on irait
recevoir la quatrième dose
bientôt?
- Dans l'même avis du comité sur
l'immunisation de la semaine
dernière, on dit bien que
quelqu'un qui vient de faire la
covid qui a été vacciné avec de
dose et qui a fait la covid
depuis l'arrivée de l'vague
micro, cette personne est bien
protégée et si elle veut
recevoir une dose additionnelle
pour avoir sa troisième dose, on
lui dit de ne pas y aller avant
trois mois. Donc ce n'est pas
qu'elle doit y aller au plus
tard dans trois mois c'est que
vous êtes bien protégé si vous
voulez malgré tout avoir une
dose, n'y allez pas avant trois
mois.
- Attendait trois mois si vous
avez eu la covid et même si vous
n'avez pas eu la troisième dose.
Est-ce que, en terminant, sans
ce projet : est-ce qu'il ira
comme cela de cinquième et
sixième dose jusqu'à la fin des
temps?
- Je pense qu'on n'aura pas des
sixième dose aux trois mois. Par
contre, il est probable que l'on
aura à chaque saison hivernale
de la vaccination pour se
protéger contre le coronavirus
mais une vaccination qui ciblera
les gens à risque et non pas
l'ensemble de la population.
- Ce que je retiens de
l'entrevue. Si vous êtes à
risque, c'est le moment d'al